um i was wondering i have like um this
guy
he's kind of like a mixture of socialist
democrat liberal
and he pointed this thing out to me so
cancel culture we said it's more like
class solidarity
because like let's say for most of the
20th century
we didn't really like uh tolerate
homosexual transsexual voices and like
any form of media
we more like you know just uh shout it
down got rid of it
so he says it's more like class
solidarity how would your response be to
that
cancel culture is class solidarity yeah
so sort of the people that were picked
on are rising up against their
tormentors type of thing is that yeah
yeah exactly
okay uh yeah i think that's total
[ __ ] personally
um pardon my part of my french yeah i i
don't buy that
um cancel culture is
this is why we have to distinguish you
know
talk about defining things cancel
culture i think it's a real thing but we
have to like what is it exactly
because we can call anything cancel
culture any time someone you know we've
had some of these republican governors
who uh have failed to rise up in defense
of
of children and have vetoed these bills
that would um
you know in arkansas for example that
would outlaw the general mutilation
of children and then they get attacked
and they say oh this is cancer culture
because they're being criticized
that's not cancelled culture being
criticized or even being
attacked or insulted is not cancer
culture i think cancer culture is
a left-wing phenomenon because it is it
requires institutional power it's when
it's when
the especially when the power and weight
of institutions are being used against
someone to
effectively erase them from the
conversation i think that's what
canceled culture is
or it's an attempt at least to get the
institutions to do that to someone you
know
both of those things are cancelled
culture um so it's it's
these are the point is that overseeing
cancer culture
the real agents of cancer culture are
the most powerful people
in the country you know big tech and
these are also not people that were ever
victimized
many times they've been privileged and
powerful their entire lives and remain
so